at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my hands this episode is brought to you
by wealth front and this is a very
unique sponsor wealth front is a
massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
front so the question is why why is it
so popular why is it unique because you
can get services previously reserved for
the ultra wealthy but only pay pennies
on the dollar for them and this is
because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront com forward slash Tim take
the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
they put you in and if you just want to
take their advice run with it do it
yourself you can do that or as I would
you can set it and forget it and here's
why
the value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than ten asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealthfront as i
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront comm forward slash tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance
now normally when I have a sponsor on
this show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of this episode is
brought to you by Vimeo specifically a
new offering called Vimeo business I've
done a lot of collaboration with these
guys Vimeo business has all of the prior
benefits of Vimeo Pro including VIP
support whether you make videos for a
living run your own company like yours
truly or simply want to amp up your
video marketing video business is here
to help they have more than 280 million
creators and viewers worldwide and Vimeo
business makes it easier to share your
videos with a global audience and
connect with professional video makers
to bring your stories to life so if you
need assistance it's there you can also
upload up to five terabytes and store
your videos in one secure place you can
add up to 10 team members to your
account for easy collaboration and
gather feedback with seamless review
tools you can add clickable calls to
action and perhaps most interesting to
me capture email addresses directly in
the player this can help you generate
leads and drive conversion for whatever
you are trying to optimize say for a
newsletter or in fact a sales page of
some type video business helps you
optimize your videos by tracking viewer
engagement and drop-off so you can then
modify your approach or creative moving
forward and improve it and it connects
to Google Analytics for even more
insights let's check it out go to Vimeo
com forward slash Tim 10 to save 10% on
Vimeo business that's vimeo.com
/ti m10
hello boys and girls ladies and
squirrels everybody out there this is
Tim Ferriss welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is my
job to deconstruct world-class
performers of all types whether they are
chess prodigies military strategists
entertainers sports icons or otherwise
this is an in-between Assad and that
means that it is perhaps a little
shorter then you would usually find my
long-form interviews and we have a Q&A
with Shay Carl but before we get to that
I wanted to what did I want to do have a
little Alzheimer's moment there I wanted
to share an announcement if you missed
the big news I have a new book that is
coming out it is available on you name
it Barnes & Noble calm you can go to
books-a-million calm and of course
amazon.com tools of titans the subtitle
is the tactics routines and habits of
billionaires icons and world-class
performers it is the culmination of the
last two years of this podcast it is my
favorite takeaways the lessons I've
learned the tools I've applied to my own
life from all the guests including some
new guests you have not met new tips and
tricks from past guests it is the
ultimate choose your an adventure guide
to optimizing your life everything I
mean finance physical performance wisdom
I know that's a little broad but it's
got everything in it so check it out
please
tools of Titan's would love you guys to
grab one for yourselves and for the
holidays maybe as a gift or two or three
or twenty-five so check that out tools
of Titan's now back to this episode shay
carl shaycarl started off i suppose you
could say as a manual laborer and he was
working on I want to say marble
countertops are countertops when he
started his YouTube channel and his
shaped arts channel now has more than
2.3 billion views celebs like Steven
Spielberg have appeared alongside che
and his family he lives in Utah he
co-founded then maker studios which sold
to Disney for nearly 1 billion dollars
he's been married 13 years has five kids
has lost more than a hundred pounds
since his overweight peak this guy knows
a thing or two about how to radically
change the direction and velocity of
your life in the right direction so we
did a round two of the first podcast
took place after spending two days with
Shay here in San Francisco it was a
massive success and coming up on I guess
a million downloads just for that
episode alone left many listeners
wanting more so we solicited questions
and your most popular questions were
answered by Shay he tackled them in the
way only Shay can and he covers many
things how to grow YouTube following
from scratch in 2016 or 2017 the future
of ad revenue and sponsorships how he
balances capturing the moment versus
experiencing the moment something I've
asked him about myself his greatest
obstacles in life
lessons learned as a father the one
person he'd love to record a video with
and much much more
so two things check out tools of Titan's
on your retailer of choice it is
available right now and without further
ado as I always say after a long-winded
intro please enjoy this round two with
Shay Carl alright this is for tim
ferriss podcast round two our very first
question is from Tony Lucas Tony asks if
you were able to start fresh no
followers no name for yourself no
previous knowledge and you had to just
start from scratch
do you think that you would still be
able to make a business out of YouTube I
have thought about this question and
have many times during panels said no I
would not be able to recreate the amount
of success I've had simply because I was
lucky enough to be ahead of the curve
you know in any industry or business or
product there's kind of like a luck to
just being there when it all happened
and if you feel like you weren't there
when it all happened I felt that way as
well I remember always feeling like when
is my thing gonna come around and it was
like that scene from Dumb and Dumber at
the very end when like the supermodels
were asking for too
boys to follow him around and they're
like man our opportunity will come one
of these days he just got to be like
Lloyd and Christopher what was their
names your opportunity will come what's
the definition of success when
preparation meets opportunity
so you kind of have to be looking for
that so if I had to start all over again
brand-new on YouTube I don't think I
would you know be able to build the
business that I have built simply
because you know I was there ahead of
the you know the curve but yeah there's
definitely a way that you can make money
on YouTube if you you know hate your job
and you think that video production is
the life for you there's definitely a
way to do it there are people that I
know that they only get 30,000 views a
day but they have a nice little income
from sharing their life for their
experience I think and this is another
question Corbin Smith asked is the daily
vlogger space now oversaturated yes and
it's really hard to stick out it's
really hard to be different couple
things one it's definitely oversaturated
two I know that marketers don't love the
daily vlogging set up they can't package
that advertisers can't you know sell
that to a TV show they can't be like
well it's kind of a reality show but
there's not always like a story arc it's
just like this guy who like turns the
camera on and it's him and his family
for 20 minutes a day but it gets a
million views but that's kind of hard to
sell so sale sell so they want more of
like package programming where you know
they can see oh this is a series or
whatever but what I do think is an
untapped market in daily vlogging is
specific life daily vlogging for
instance I would love to be able to you
know wake up and say I wonder what a
gold miner does everyday or what does a
deep-sea fishermen do everyday I think
there are opportunities for daily
vlogging in which you share a specific
niche thing that not a lot of people get
to see you know so maybe you're a logger
in Alaska I know a guy mr. safety Corey
Williams
SMP films he's been a youtuber around
for a long time he now does daily vlogs
living in Alaska so if you're like man
what would it be like to just pack up
and move on out to Alaska there's a guy
doing that and him and his wife just had
a kid and they're living in Alaska and
not like off the land or anything but
you kind of get an X you know see what
it's like to be in Alaska and I think
there's a lot of opportunity for that so
what do you do what's different about
your life and you may say well nothing
I've got a boring life well not
everybody is the hashbrown cook at
McDonald's and I love those hashbrowns
and I want to know the do when he woke
up in the morning what was he thinking
before he went cook the best hash bread
this is not a sponsor deal by the way
but you have a unique experience and you
just have to figure out what do I do
that nobody else does and that could be
work at Staples that could be you know
you live in a different part of the
world that you may think is average
because you've just been there your
whole life but people want to know
people that's why people watch our
videos it's that voyeurism aspect of
getting out of your own head it's why we
go to movies and TV and that's why art
has been so popular over all of the
species because we just want to kind of
get out of our own experience and evolve
that experience by allowing other
experiences in so I think daily vlogging
even though it's oversaturated and maybe
a business that's going out you still
can build an audience I still believe
that you know YouTube is a cool place to
meet fellow minded people you don't ever
have to feel lonely again because
there's lots of different types of
people so if you are gonna you know give
a give it a go say I'm gonna try to make
this YouTube business my business like I
want to you know be a youtuber I would
say you definitely have to go and look
at all the things that the you know
career youtubers are doing like where do
they put annotations
what's an annotation where do you put
links in the video description where do
they have their intro little just little
things like that that you could kind of
mimic and those are like marketing tech
and just ways to promote other you know
projects that you're working on but
that's definitely something I would do
is is just do what the professionals are
doing that's I think the best life well
some of the best life advice if you want
to be something just do the same thing
that a person that has what you want
does so if you want to be a fat lazy
person do what fat lazy people do and
vice versa
alright good questions Alexander coffee
recently asked recently a number of
high-profile vloggers have been having
issues with detrimental effects on their
social and/or relationship lives as a
result of the excessive time
that is consumed by producing daily
vlogs have you ever experienced anything
like this if so what are your methods of
dealing with it and how can they be
applied to non vloggers well you know
this is a question you know it's a tale
as old as time people break up and
recently there's some been some
high-profile vloggers that have broken
up and I don't think that's specific to
vlogging is vlogging detrimental on your
relationship it can be anything can be I
listened I said this prefix um where
before I can't remember where but I
basically listened to everything my wife
says twice because she says it and then
I edit it and you know if you're not if
you're not too friendly with you know
your spouse that could get annoying
really fast and you really those little
you know we all have them idiosyncrasies
that are all part of our personalities
whether it be you know be loud obnoxious
like me or you know maybe you say
something the same way or you fold the
toothpaste tube in a awkward direction
whatever it is those things come out
when you daily vlog because you start to
see those things not only you know when
you're like trying to vlog things all
the time but when you're editing your
just like speech impediments that you
have I've noticed I've tried to take out
the UM zand the all that kind of stuff
so I think vlogging is at
ashlee therapeutic I think it can be
helpful in a self examined life I think
it helps you to kind of like look at
your own personality and see is that
exactly how I want to be and my
obnoxious sometimes or do I need to be
more patient or whatever so it can be
good or it can like really bring out
those annoying aspects of your
significant other so it's just uh it's
love love is a verb this is the best
advice I have for relationships you got
to serve the other person love doesn't
come from a magical song from a movie
it comes from service so if you think
about what a verb is you know that's an
action word means you got a man yeah by
flowers we got to write notes yeah I
like put the note underneath the
windshield wiper of your you know wife
when she's like parked somewhere you got
a stalker no don't do that but remember
like I was I was given a lesson
yesterday about marriage and it's like
remember what you did when you were
trying to get that girl to marry you so
you have sex with her why don't you why
don't know husbands do that stuff
anymore when you probably tried to get
her to marry you for other reasons too
but you can remember your primal
motivation as dude so think about that
love is a verb do things be kind wash
dishes change diapers and then you have
a happy marriage happy relationship okay
next question Fadi Salah who knows I
can't pronounce words right asks for the
vast majority of content creators
traditional monetization strategies like
ad revenue and sponsorships ie brand
deals seem unsustainable due to their
low earnings per view yes that is true
what do you think is the future of ad
revenue and sponsorships do you think
that will continue to be the primary
monetization scheme for years to come I
don't know nobody knows we're all trying
to figure it out we're all trying to say
where is this business heading it is
true that trying to make a living just
off of monetizing your videos and if you
know you're kind of listening to this
like what do all these words mean if you
make a youtube video you get paid on
that
video based on how many people watch
that video so I as a youtuber could have
1 billion subscribers and I go to upload
a video and hypothetically that video is
supposed to be sent out through
YouTube's distribution platform to all 1
billion of my subscribers and in a
perfect world all 1 billion of them will
watch because you know they subscribe to
my channel so of course they want to
watch every piece of content that I
upload but maybe only a thousand people
watch that video that I uploaded and I'm
like what happened to the other 999
million 900 whatever that number is and
I have a little video here with 1,000
views on it I'll make about 2 bucks on
that video they have a thing and this
has been explained a lot of times in
different ways I've done it in different
places but it's a CPM is what they call
it cost per Mille or in other words how
much money do you get paid on YouTube I
make about 2 bucks per thousand views so
if I was to give you this little piece
of paper and say hey run out and show
this to a thousand people and I'll give
you 2 bucks you can imagine how
profitable that might be and how tiring
that would be as well so because of the
internet and networking and the 8
billion people in the world hopefully
one of they will all get the internet
one day but you're able to show these
videos to thousands of people and make
money through the CPM but you really
have to be getting a lot of views every
day in order to you know be able to make
some money to live on YouTube so the
other way that youtubers have done it is
through brand deals or commercials for
big you know companies whether it's Nike
Reebok any big company you can think of
with the brightly colored logo that you
see driving down the Main Street of your
hometown they pay influencers for lack
of a better term youtubers Viners
snapchatters people that have an
audience people that you know have
people that are willing to listen to
them they'll pay him big bucks to
promote their brand and that's something
that's brand new where previously
advertising was traditionally done
through newspapers magazines you know
all the
out rap revenue out where I'm
translating outlets but now it's like
this whole internet thing has blown up
and advertisers or owners of companies
that are paying to get people to see
their product are realizing that these
youtubers these influencers these people
with audiences their promotion is way
more valuable than buying advertising
time on a commercial of a TV show or you
know before a movie or whatever because
what is the very best form of
advertising i'ma let you think about it
in your brain for a minute this is a
multi you got to think during this
podcast it's word of mouth right any
business owner will say if I could get
one of my customers to go tell their
best friend about how great my business
is we've made it right it's word of
mouth you want people to just be talking
and being like this is awesome you gotta
go try Joe's Crab Shack you gotta go try
it you know whatever it is whatever your
business is that has traditionally
always been the very best way to grow a
business is by having your customers
tell their friends and with a youtuber
like myself for instance who's been
making a video every day for almost a
decade I've kind of created a pretty
good relationship with these people who
watch my videos and so for a brand or an
advertiser to say like hey person that
has four million best friends could you
go tell all of those best friends that
really trust you because they've watched
your dog die and watch you make to human
people and birth them out of your wife
that sounded weird um they're gonna
trust you will you go tell all these
people to check out our product and
we'll give you X amount of dollars and
of course then you think well how
they're the whole discussion comes like
well how do you put a value on that how
much in everybody's like how much how
much how much will a giant company pay a
big youtuber and you can go to places
like social Bluebook that have a
proprietary algorithm that takes
everything into account we're talking to
work this is more than views like yeah
great you got a thousand people to watch
your video I mean you can that's a
measurable number you can look at right
away
but there's other factors that
advertisers are really starting to look
at more than just views and subscribers
and it's a thing called engagement they
want to see that whoever's watching or
you know being part of this community is
thumbs een up favoriting commenting what
type of engagement are they touching the
content in some way even if it's a skip
ad I have I thought I've heard that you
know you are even rewarded for somebody
clicking that skip ad button because
then the advertiser knows that that
person at least saw the product because
they had to you know scroll their little
mouse up there to click on the skip ad
and they're more than likely to see
whatever you're advertising there so you
know at least they saw the thing and had
to click to say go away
so there's value there where before you
don't know if the person watching TV got
up to go pee or to make some guacamole
during the commercial break so you have
no idea if they saw the thing that you
made went into their brain but now even
on the computer if they say skip ad like
I don't want to watch this crap they
still saw the thing they're skipping
which still registers uh-oh this is a
product on the market that is available
to me so this is valuable this is very
valuable and then you got to decide well
how valuable is it and my job as a
creator and as a friend of fellow
creators is to say hey guys let's make
ourselves valuable because we've been
working for 10 years to build these
audience of people who trust us and my
job as a creator is one not to do a
bunch of these brand deals like check
this out check this out check this out
cuz then all sudden I lose that value
with my audiences like man this dude's
just promoting everything he must be
making Bank I don't gonna buy any of his
crappy slingin so as a creator and I
suggest this to other creators is be
careful only do brand deals for things
that you really love wow that was a long
question - how else can I get paid -
money on the youtubes all right next
question
Lycia Mauer English asks how did it feel
to tell the truth about alcoholism on
Tim's podcast last time healing or
painful or both did you find that
telling the truth is a healing practice
yes
like how daily writing has been studied
and found to be healing physically and
emotionally yeah it needs
you can talk about your weaknesses or
things that you're afraid of is
ultimately gonna be hugely therapeutic
and may help you make leaps and bounds
in your personal happiness and struggle
if you feel like you can be in a place
to talk about the things that scare you
most because that's what we're all
struggling with is that stuff that is it
we're afraid of and you might be like
I'm gonna fruit and mildewed it's just
because you haven't lived long enough
and you haven't been faced with some
realities that are part of your future
that once you do gain a little age and
experience but oh yeah I guess I'm kind
of afraid of that but you'll see it felt
great I wasn't planning on talking about
that on Tim Ferriss podcast we were just
sitting there in his kitchen and he gets
you all loosened up by being all
friendly and all sudden you're sharing
your Oprah story with him he I don't
know how it came up we were just talking
and I told him that that was something
that I had struggled with I think that
he had specifically asked what's
something that you've struggled with and
that was something and I was like I
don't know though cuz I've never like
exposed that or told my audience about
that and he said he was awesome he said
well if you feel like talking about it
that'd be great let's talk about it but
if not you know we can edit it out he
gives all of his interviewees the option
the you know final edit option so they
can be like you know I don't feel great
about this will you take that out but
after um after I said it and it felt
good and I just like let's just get it
out there I was nervous but then the the
feedback was awesome and I feel like I
encourage people to try to talk about
their scars and about the things that
are scary to them because they'll find
that there is really a kind listening
ear a lot of the times and maybe not
maybe people have tried to open up and
you know but you have to do it sometimes
it's hard to open up to the ones that
are closest to you right because that's
where those fights come but yeah Alicia
did feel great and we talked about
recently on one of our podcasts with the
writing example that you gave a great
way to practice this without the you
know the fear of being judged by this
person that you love is
to try a practice of writing down all of
your fears and everything that you're
frustrated about and all that stuff on a
piece of paper knowing that you're gonna
destroy it you're gonna tear it up
you're gonna burn it nobody's ever gonna
see it I think that is similar to you
know being able to talk about these
things but without the repercussion and
the fear of you know somebody judging
you so try that first write it all down
and then just say I'm gonna write down
the scariest most painful things that I
keep inside and I know I'm gonna burn it
but it just the the actual act of
writing it down and seeing those words
can have a drastic impact on how you
feel about them so give it a try nothing
to lose except for a piece of paper and
that's not expensive okay next question
Tim McGee asks Shay if you had two weeks
to teach someone how to tell a better
story on YouTube what would that course
look like uh I don't know if I've ever
actually thought of curriculum for what
a teaching a good storytelling class
might be but it's a I think it's a way
of thinking I just remember as a kid my
buddy would be telling me stories I bet
I can that what happen and then what
they say and then it's all about details
you know it's about those little things
that maybe when you're telling a story
you don't think of I just I learned
storytelling from my grandpa I think my
grandpa was a great storyteller and
being a good storyteller is just the the
ability to help somebody become present
in a different situation you know so how
do you make a story exciting you have to
be passionate about it so you have to
pick the stories that you tell
right you have to think they're funny I
think you can't just you know try to
tell a story that you're not passionate
about because that definitely reads but
it's details it's the little things like
and then she said this but you know just
looking past the storyline and trying to
read the subtext of maybe what's
happening underneath the surface I don't
know I don't think I have a great answer
to that question but the details and
emotion so like if you're telling the
story
a lot of times when I'm telling the
story I'll be like and this happened
this happened but here's the frame of
mine that I was coming from I was
frustrated because this just happened
and because that just happened I was
worried about this happen anyways here I
was being you know and so it's like you
kind of have to have backstory you have
to have emotion attached to it why did
this person feel like that what was
their motivation for feeling like that I
don't know that's uh that's something I
would actually like to delve into
because it is a very valuable thing
being able to tell a story just being
able to communicate I've always looked
up to people who could do that well I
think that was the very first thing that
attracted me to Philip defranco's videos
I was like dude this guy can talk and
even if it is edited it's jump Cuddy the
way that it was you know delivered of
the way that it was created was
entertaining and it was like I am
laughing and learning at the same time
and to be able to do that as something
that is a learned ability you have to
practice it it's like your voice I
remember my dad and my program director
from z103 said that your voice is like a
muscle you can work it out you talked to
any voice actor they can inflect and
come down and do all these different you
know characters and impressions simply
because they practiced it they talked a
lot I am able to communicate a lot
better because I've just been doing it
for 10 years and if you look at Malcolm
Gladwell's book he talks about how you
become an expert is by simply doing a
thing for 10,000 hours exactly that's
all it takes
so great question just tell stories man
you become a better storyteller Amy
Gilligan asks other than having better
shoes how has money changed you if at
all what does that mean you like my
shoes Amy I have been buying Jordans I
got somehow into the shoe game I I don't
know I've always liked Jordans I thought
they're cool and apparently there's
Jordans out there they're like $600 it's
ridiculous I have fallen into that a
little bit um I would like to say money
has not changed us if I'm honest
the reason I started YouTube wasn't for
the pursuit of money but the reason that
I've kept going so long is because of
money like when I first found YouTube it
was simply like an avenue of escape it
was like this whole other world where I
could type in anything I wanted Green
Day concert Glen Plake scheme whatever I
thought was cool and it would pop up and
the communication just like man I can
talk to people just that first
realization that I had when 200 people
subscribe to my videos and I was like
200 people these are real people with
hands and opinions and favorite colors
and dislikes and food and who are these
people that first realization of I'm
hanging out with other people on the
internet like we are transcending
geographical boundaries just because
we're not in the same room doesn't mean
that we're not actually really hanging
out here so the first time I realized
that that was the addicting thing but
then once I found out you can make money
I was like oh I got kids man I gotta
kind of pay for these kids to do stuff
and money was never the goal it was just
freedom I never wanted to be like I want
to be rich so I can have all this stuff
I just wanted to be able to not go to
work right I just wanted to be able to
tell the guy who I called my boss that
hey guess what I'm gonna actually go
waterskiing with my family today just
because we decided we wanted to and I
know that I'm supposed to be in at work
but like I just I hated that I hated
feeling like I was being controlled by a
dude that I was tied to $11 an hour -
it's like man this guy can tell me what
how to live my life for 11 bucks an hour
that what I'm worth so it was never
about the money was about the freedom
and I tell this story like the day that
maker studios sold the day that that I
for all intents and purposes became a
millionaire I remember like looking in
our account and it was like oh geez and
then it was like kleberkuh let my wife
called me on the phone and I said to her
I said did you see the account she's
like yes and I'm like that cool she's
like yeah
and then I was like what's for dinner
because like nothing change was like we
still had to like feed the kids who said
to brush their teeth change their
diapers you know wasn't like and I guess
we could have I guess we could have said
all right kid on a yacht we're out of
here
but we didn't get that much money I
think a lot of people think that we got
like hundreds of millions of dollars we
did not so money just makes you more of
who you already are right so sometimes
you see that people that win the lottery
for instance they'll just like run their
life into the ground because all sudden
they're like you know just buying all
the you know things that they were
buying before but just in excess so
money doesn't matter to us and I'd like
to say that like I'm definitely
motivated by it but um I'd like to think
that it hasn't changed me and I you know
I I try to be aware of that because I
don't want it to right so I don't want
to just say money hasn't changed me I'm
still me but maybe it has maybe it
hasn't ways that I don't realize but I
don't want it to so therefore I'm
conscious of like don't do or say things
that might make you seem like just a
money greedy jerk not and it's not like
I am that secretly and I don't want to
reveal it it just like you decide what
kind of person you are and so if you see
stuff like that coming out and you you
can be like whoa I don't that's not how
I want to be like I'm let me think about
that so my goal is to not let money
change me and just to use it for good to
use it to help others and I know that
sounds like that's good for you yeah I
would buy some cool shoes too and a
water-ski boat I'm gonna go on vacation
and I don't look at the prices of things
the only time I ever looked at the price
of something is if I like I want quality
I'll just like what's the most expensive
one that must be the best one which
isn't always necessarily true but
sometimes it's a pretty good uh you know
indicator of what is the best when I'm
looking for my new camera or skateboard
or whatever so yeah I follow Dave Ramsey
still I do not borrow money I pay cash
for everything that's how I got to where
I'm at
I decided to stay out of the rat race I
cut up my credit cards I didn't listen
to this 90 days same as cash
and I know people are like well you're
rich now that's easy well I started off
broke I was like making 20 grand a year
but I just followed these rules there
are certain specific things that you can
do that if you just follow these rules
you can't help but to become rich save
10 percent of your income no matter what
a lot of people have this ten ten eighty
rule ten percent of tithing if you don't
believe in God or tithing you don't have
to pay that pay yourself twenty percent
but a lot of people do ten percent of
tithing 10% to themselves and then 80
percent goes to everything else so right
away the richest man in Babylon it's a
little book maybe like a hundred pages I
read when I was a kid the number one
principle in that book was pay yourself
first you get a paycheck whether it's a
small paycheck a big paycheck whatever
you get paid somehow salary allowance
maybe your mom and dad give you a few
nickels to rake the leaves I don't know
what you do to get your money but you do
something whatever that money is you
take 10% off the top right away you say
I'm paying me first like what do you
mean that paycheck is all mine no it's
not it's going to gas and groceries and
food and you owe your buddy five bucks
because you lost the fantasy bull draft
whatever you do but always as a rule any
money you ever get say 10% of that is
future mine like retired mine like
sitting on a beach somewhere not have to
worry about all this Shi T mine so if
you follow that rule from when you're
like 12 13 15 16 first time you ever get
your job you always save 10% of
everything that money's gonna grow
little soldiers so soldiers out there
fighting for you and that's how the
richest man in Babylon talks about this
money that you set aside these 10% these
little soldiers that got and work for
you and invest those and stuff like that
so who was the question how much money
do I have not a lot but I'm rich in
blessings all right next question Amy
thanks for the last one appreciate it
Thomas Owen Thomas I'm assuming that's
Thomas Owen asks right Thomas Thomas
Thomas Owen asked what do you do to
overcome doubt that's a tough one
because you go in fits and bouts with
doubt depending on the morning depend
the mood depending on the oh it's Monday
you do doubt I mean and it's different
for different people I think it starts
at your upbringing you know what did
your mom and dad tell you did your mom
and dad tell you you could do it or did
they tell you you couldn't do it I think
a lot of it more than we would like to
admit comes from our upbringing the
personal internal struggles that we have
and that might like feel bad to some
moms and dads out there but a lot of the
kind of crap that we carry around like
self-doubt and fear inferiority you know
anxiousness all that I think stems from
those developmental years of being a kid
and that's why families are so important
that's why moms and dads are so
important because we carry around a lot
of this baggage for the rest of our
lives so how do I get over doubt some
days you don't you know it's like a
battle everything's a battle happiness
as a choice as a battle being confident
in what you're saying and what you want
to do as a battle and yes a lot of times
it's a fake it till you make it kind of
mentality where it's like you there's
not a good tip or trick and other than
just do it other than just like you have
to tell yourself do not doubt believe
you just hope for good things to come I
love you guys know I'm always quoting
Andy what's-his-name
Shawshank Redemption my favorite one of
my favorite movies Shawshank Redemption
I said at the end hope is a good thing
and it's maybe one of the best of things
cuz without hope there's NAS darkness
you know you think about concentration
camps I remember I was talking about
that book the other day like the only
thing sometimes you can have is hope and
Andy Dufresne said it and that's what
you have to do to overcome doubt you
just have to say and I always go back to
this I think it's like a little jarring
for people or but I'm just like you're
gonna die if you have this healthy
realization that you will lose the
opportunity
to have effect on the world because your
body will pass away it will give you I
think hopefully not an anxiousness but
you know some kind of a sense of ain't
not anxious and I don't to use that term
of proactivity hopefully were you
realize it's you know we have limited
amount of time and regret is such a
painful thing so just go for it what you
got to lose like you have to look at
failures as just stepping stones because
people are always like what if I mess up
what if I fail what if I lose everything
then that's like so what like start over
you think about you know the guy who
invented electricity what I don't know
all the statistics are they failed
thousand times you know it's all about
how you get up you know those little
clichés are true so it's sometimes just
gritting through it and I sure I don't
have any better tips and tricks for you
but uh it's up to you Thomas hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by Vimeo
specifically a new offering called Vimeo
business I've done a lot of
collaboration with these guys Vimeo
business has all of the prior benefits
of the
Pro including VIP support whether you
make videos for a living
run your own company like yours truly or
simply want to amp up your video
marketing video business is here to help
they have more than 280 million creators
and viewers worldwide and Vimeo business
makes it easier to share your videos
with a global audience and connect with
professional video makers to bring your
stories to life so if you need
assistance it's there you can also
upload up to five terabytes and store
your videos in one secure place you can
add up to ten team members to your
account for easy collaboration and
gather feedback with seamless review
tools you can add clickable calls to
action and perhaps most interesting to
me a capture email addresses directly in
the player this can help you generate
leads and drive conversion for whatever
you are trying to optimize say for a
newsletter or in fact a sales page of
some type video business helps you
optimize your videos by tracking viewer
engagement and drop-off so you can then
modify your approach or creative moving
forward and improve it and it connects
to Google Analytics for even more
insights so check it out go to Vimeo
comm forward slash
Tim 10 to save 10% on Vimeo business
that's vimeo.com slash TI m10 this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash Tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it
here's
the value of wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than ten asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealth front as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show is because I use them and recommend
them in this case it's a little
different I don't use wealthfront yet
because I'm not allowed to here's the
deal
they wanted to sponsor this podcast but
because of SEC regulations companies
that invest your money are not allowed
to use client testimonials so I couldn't
be a user and have them on the podcast
but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
dot-com forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of
you